[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
spy mania returns the u.s. weapon eise's
its laws against adversaries also is the
Western world in crisis and much much
more on this edition of crosstalk
[Music]
Krauss some real news i'm joined
by my guests here in moscow mark sloboda
he's an international affairs and
security analyst we also have Dimitri
Babak she is a political analyst with
Sputnik International and we have Glenn
DS and he is a professor at the higher
School of Economics as well as author of
the decay of Western civilization and
resurgence of Russia
all right gentlemen crosstalk rules in
effect that means you can jump in any
time you want and I always appreciate
since you wrote a book about the topic I
will go to you first we all read the
article recent article by Pat Buchanan
here what lies behind the melees of the
West I thought it was a really
fascinating article because he really
kind of hit the nail on the head it's
really about a crisis of confidence in
many ways
what was your case well we touched on
this topic in previous segments I think
it all goes back to this system we put
together after the Cold War it's been a
very liberal format for globalization
and all during in 1990s it was realized
that it wouldn't work for everyone and
it was a fuller ization between the
leads and the people I think in the
European Union we were able to we'll
cover some of these problems through
2000 spy simply ignoring referendums or
making them vote again I can keep
expanding yeah but then something has
now happened over the last two or three
years in which first we have the brexit
then the election of Trump there's been
some attempts to walk that back I guess
well so breaks it's not really gonna
mean brexit and you know the effort to
essentially yeah but we'll see the same
problem out in Europe you can only hold
it back for so long before it comes out
in different forms so the only two
powers left in to hold the earth
together has been
France and Germany but now as we see
McCrone he and Merkel is not gone very
well Merkel is now accepted as to step
down but but only to be replaced with
molecule two essentially it's
interesting right because it's it seems
to me that them they've relied more upon
ideology than on leadership okay because
the ideology is a substitution for
leadership I think that's an important
part of
the EU project specifically I mean this
is backlash this is a neoliberal Pro
globalization Pro globalist if you want
to use that elite who have forced both
economic and social radical reforms on
the peoples of Europe and also the
United States and Canada over the heads
of the people using you know these
repeat referendums and repeat votes in
the EU right the US and Canada using the
distraction of identity politics and
this is done with with a triangulated
center right center left parties and
we're finally seeing the backlash and
it's coming from the far right and the
far left as we've talked about
repeatedly on this show and now we've
seen outbreaks of it in the United
States with the election of Trump in in
Germany with with the you know the the
Grand Chancellor Merkel having to stand
down in the German elite just not
knowing what comes after Merkel and and
you know the her whole political party
is is being crushed in the polls right
now because of her you know mass
immigration that she and Bernie guard
France rocked by protests against the
then weak link and look at the may raise
it then we have made say Italy Poland
Hungary interesting this whole ideology
is predicated on destroying nations
absolutely well and fabricating writes
about it he writes that loyalty to
family tribe neighborhood cultured
country be a paramount rising above
intellectual and political alignments
well the problem is which intellectual
alignments what has been offered the
people you know we have basically the
same outer liberal narrative both mostly
in the United States in the mainstream
and in Europe and you know what happened
in France you know the the problem is
that the outer liberal state according
to its ideology it's not doing anything
in industry it allows big companies do
it it's not doing anything in science
what it is doing is
seyton the rules of the game and you
have so many bureaucrats and they have
to be busy every day so they invent for
example yellow vests you know for some
reason all the people need to wear
yellow vests in their cars and then
what's the response from the people ah
you wanted to see us you will see us but
not only in the cars in the streets so
it's a backlash against stupid rules
against the second rule is there any
learning curve here I mean it seems to
me that the elites here maintain their
idea because their ideology is a new
catechism and they can't adjust it in
light of what's happening on the ground
to normal people well I think the EU is
extraordinary incapable of doing
anything about it because the whole
institution's built up on the idea that
nationalism is inherently a bad thing
and we need to elevate above it however
with this
I guess contempt for nationalism and it
was often referred as tribalism it is
strange because this it's often assumed
to be on a negative thing but I keep in
mind that the nation-state has been the
most strongest vehicle to promote human
freedoms and tribalism it's not
inherently a bad thing I mean if you
care more about your kid than random
here that's a good thing like social
fabric it's not the local level at the
regional level the fact that the idea
that you would have the same affinity
towards your neighbors people are like
us on the other side of the world it's
not how human nature work it would be
great if we were this global village but
the tribe that counts most
are these elitist with their ideology
nice the tribe it's also a matter of
political representation because we have
this transnational ultra wealthy ultra
politic privileged economic and
political elite that associate with and
get along with and have far more in
common than the cosmopolitan peers
around the world than they do with their
own people in their own countries well
directs creates a backlash I'm glad you
know in Charles Dickens novel the Bleak
House you have a character who cares
about kids in Africa kids in Asia kids
in Latin America and she doesn't care
about her own kids who are hungry in
that same house so the idea is not that
you don't care about others what about
the nation's the idea of national state
is if you can't if you can't care about
your own country about your own kids you
won't be able you won't be able to
properly care about the others and this
is the right message last word on this
yeah I'll just say that this is what is
the problem in bricks it now because if
you look at that people wanted to remain
they're all essentially said they're
aligning themselves more with the lead
so look at the speech sub-layer for
example it's not saying let's respect
democracy this is you know this is a
pride of the English instead he's saying
listen Eurocrats you have to help us to
get out of this this vote and this is
this is what what is making a lot of
people upset so even if they're able to
overturn it imagine he saw the favor
Kratz helps resume when she went person
here we all want to go change the spy
mania here deema oona we should she get
justice in the united states go well i
mean the whole idea that basically you
can plead guilty and get a reduced
sentence for a crime that you didn't
commit
it's just awful I mean it's good it goes
against the Constitution of the United
States the fifth amendment no one should
be forced to testify against oneself but
what happened with Putin is that they
offered her this deal you know violating
the foreign agents basically for posting
her photos with lower rank Republican or
NRA you know officials on their own
Facebook and they called her a spy for
that you know spies do not post their
pictures on facebook but but I am
reading from The Guardian you know
someone named David Smith writes in the
headline Russian spy Maria Putin are you
know
pleads guilty in the US and and it's
it's amazing that first they had this
charge that she was how did they put it
she was getting ahead trading sex for
getting ahead in her influence
operations which is not which is no
evidence of that one they dropped it but
please note where did all the
feminism goal when they when they have a
woman whom they suspect of acting
against them it's exactly you know like
Bolsheviks Bolsheviks talked about
proletariat but if proletarians turned
against them the Bolsheviks are hardest
on them the same stories here here is a
woman who they whom they suspect of not
of being disloyal and they crush her
only crime is that she's Russian here
Glenn if when I find more outrageous not
only was she not given justice is it how
many thousands and thousands of people
in Washington DC lobby for foreign
governments that are not registered with
the government and they get away with it
are they running that way took my
punchline marker well well first in
terms of defining the spy you have to
first go and acquire information and
hand it over to your they need not you
know your intelligence services and she
wasn't actually acquiring the acquiring
a legal information and she will
selectively handing it off to any or
having this contact with any security
officer so again this the spy definition
it fails on both ends of what a spy
supposed to do seems to happen have
happened that they wanted her to sing
and she ended up composing yeah this is
as much a failure instead of the Justice
it is even more of failure of the media
constantly this refrain Russian spy
Russian spy she is not accused of
espionage she was not found guilty of
espionage they have not accused her of
having any contacts with Russian
intelligence
she hasn't acquired any information what
she is accused of with this foreign
agent register act is being an
unregistered lobbyist she supported gun
rights she supported gun rights in
Russia
she was actually censored online in
LiveJournal her posts were blocked by
the Russian government which is not a
fan of the American conception of rights
for guns or whatever it is
and if anything you know she has her and
this patron of her as a banker that they
are support gun rights in both countries
they lobbied with the NRA they also
l'arbre did the EU Hubley all in public
and she was as much a vehicle of trying
to force the influence of American gun
culture on Russia even more than the
other way around now you have a few
years ago she would never have been
arrested this has to be put in the
context of the election of Trump because
they've been for so long now trying to
come with the smoking gun that Trump is
this Russian agent and now he's finding
out this Russian coming along conference
a short break and after that short break
we'll continue our discussion on some
real news stay with her Nick welcome
back to crosstalk where all things are
considered I'm Peter LaBelle remind you
we're discussing some real news
[Music]
okay Glenn let's go back to the
weaponization of the law boo Tina is not
the only story in the news where the US
weaponized the law what's the what's the
second one well the second would be what
has happened with the executive from
Hawaii from China as well she was also
arrested in Canada and is now awaiting
extradition to the United States and
again this is also yeah you can argue
that it's also weaponizing the law to
similar extent this watch was done
against Maria Bettina in to the extent
that she would never be in the rest
individuals for the alleged crimes of
their own company's personal crimes
right embezzlement but if your company
has done they argue that they broken
some laws which which is controversial
on its own you would go after companies
starting to wrest the executives this is
something new though is absurd and it's
obviously a political it's a kidnap for
ransom she's accused of providing
misleading information in a presentation
to HSBC US UK bank that facilitated a
subsidiary companies no longer connected
with huai's wealth transfer money
transfers over the head of unilateral
illegal US sanctions which were all
erased by a UN Security Council
resolution which the US also signed up
to and this is is being presented no
it's clear that this was planned months
in advance we know this it was worked
out with the Canadian Prime Minister any
protestations of innocence all we had to
do it because of you know the
extradition request no it was plenty
they were looking at other ways to get
her they were looking specifically at
other things tech transfer and other
things this is a shot across the bow at
China at Chinese companies and they
picked one person that they could reach
out and grab it
and Trump could not have made it more
obvious when he tweeted out that this is
political by saying we could arrange her
release it's part of leverage with a
trade deal so much for you as
independent or in the Communist era that
was called telephone justice well but I
think the most alarming thing is when
how to liberals of all the people start
having questions because it just goes
over the board Jeffrey Sachs of all the
people yeah
analyze the the arrest of this Chinese
woman and he if you wrote in his article
the war on Huawei in 2011 JP Morgan
Chase paid eighty eight million in 2011
for violating US sanctions against Cuba
yet Jamie Dimon wasn't grabbed off a
plane and waste into custody but two
Canadians at least as we speak were
arrested by the Chinese China stands up
and defends their national interests
unfortunately we don't see the Russian
government doing the same over the case
of Maria who do rose to China with with
Putin ah there's another ultra liberal
down at the shitski on Bloomberg a good
who notices you know that the the and
the final wave of all the separation
please before explain the political
persuasions of the author well he is the
most outré liberal of all the Russian
ultra liberal authors who went to Europe
in in the 2000 in 1999 he refused to put
the story on the apartment bombings in
which hundreds of people died you know
that Chechen terrorists then exploded
several apartment buildings in Moscow
and he refused to put it on the front
page because it's just some Soviet
people dead you know so this kind of
person is concerned about any rights for
Bloomberg and Bloomberg he writes that
it seems to be that the case is that
they want to let it be known after what
the US intelligence community considers
massive interference in the presidential
election no unofficial back channels to
Russia will be tolerated
and of course well this is really
dangerous
because unofficial back channel saved us
from several real threats of nuclear war
including required on a backhand channel
verted the Cuban mission during during
the 1967 war you know when the Israeli
troops were getting close to kun a tree
in Syria it was the back channel that
saved the situation you know solitude
was ready to react it's interesting they
want to make it exist it seems that this
the the Trump administration it's a
shout over everyone's bow simultaneously
this is a very interesting I don't think
I've ever seen anything quite like it I
mean the United States wants to be
America first I understand that but that
means at the expense of everyone else
that is something a little bit different
than where we've had before yeah but we
are entering choppy waters times I mean
if you look at the broad spectrum what
was really happened over the last few
centuries has been that the West was
really put in the driver's seat after
the first Industrial Revolution in the
in the mid 18th century and since then
you had the second with combustion
engine the third with the computer chip
and superconductors and so essentially
the West has always been in the driver
seat now forget the fire something
different is happening we have this year
industrial revolution with with
artificial intelligence robotics
automation not only not in the West but
the Chinese are actually set to set have
leadership in all this so suddenly after
the first Industrial Revolution which is
100 years later on killed off China in
the opium wars now essentially they're
coming back into the driver's seat so
this is a huge shift in history and also
for the first time in almost 500 years
the Western loose with losing its
primacy
so all of this happening at once and as
we discussed last week who is one of the
company's leading this technological if
we mark if we just take with Glenn had
said this said there the u.s. in its
behavior is accelerating yes this yeah
well they're not alleviate it's
accelerating you know it the process is
somewhat irreversible and with this
global neoliberal capitalist
architecture that they assemble that you
know globalization runs on they
created it they don't have a really way
of stop it they're desperate they're
trying everything they can and this
extraterritorial extension of US laws
laws which aren't recognized anywhere
else like these unilateral sanctions not
illegal in Canada but Canada acting as a
pliant puppet state Trudeau went ahead
yeah all he had to do right if he really
wanted to avert it was make a call to
China and say hey don't drop by my
country in a matter of time because I
don't really want an international
incident and now he's bitten off more
than he's chew because China is is by
many measures now the world's largest
economy and which Canada is extremely
you know you know dependent on as most
countries are become and as we speak
about you know that this is not the
trade deal that the Trump wants to make
with the Chinese the trade deficit only
gets larger it's a it's not Olivia it's
getting larger this is after Trump
browbeat Trudeau with tariffs and a new
new NAFTA I want to shift gears
something very important Tim what's
going on with the Orthodox Church in
Ukraine well the the so-called
convention of the new Ukrainian Orthodox
Church took place in Kiev it was
presided for some reason by President
poroshenko talk to me about separation
of genetical figure yes a political
figure the official the real Ukrainian
Orthodox Church please don't listen to
Western media when they call with
Russian Orthodox Church
it's the Ukrainian Orthodox Church
autonomous from Russia financially you
know they appoint their own bishops
their Metropolitan seats on the council
of russian orthodox church no russian
metropolitans are seated in their Senate
so this official Ukrainian Orthodox
Church protest at this convention they
didn't attempt out of 30 bishops only
two were forced to attend even though
there were searches by the Ukrainian
Security Agency you know there was
several people were arrested still they
didn't go to this convention they said
it was not economical but a political
event and what's the reaction in the
Western media unquote in France
24 you know how did they report about it
this morning they said that Ukraine is
finally coming out of Russia out of
Russia's religious influence although
some Ukrainians are still loyal to the
wrong chose yeah so I got a quote that
sums up the import of this you know and
what is actually happening behind the
scenes here this patriarch of this
separatist splinter Ukrainian Church
filler at least up until you know the
last few hours when he was replaced
he had a awards ceremony this week where
he gave an award specifically the order
of st. Andrew to Jack Devine who is Jack
Devine Jack Devine is the áformer
associate director of the CIA and giving
him the award this this Ukrainian
patriarch quote/unquote said thank you
for our independence thank you for the
creation of our unified autocephalous
Ukrainian Orthodox Church now he's
previously also given an award to John
McKay over you know the pooch and and
his support that provided them there so
I think that pretty much sums up what is
actually going to all of this well I
mean people are dismayed but they're
also they're also terrified because you
have all over the Facebook to have
photos of these Ukrainian priests you
know there was even a flash mob you know
priests and their supporters put the
inscription I am radio for a search by
Ukrainian security service and and and
talking about the orders you know just a
few months ago there was a similarly
curious event
poroshenko the Ukrainian president gave
the order of Prince Yaroslav the wise to
general Breedlove of all the people of
the nation for supporting Ukrainian
independence the problem is that
Yaroslav the wise started as the prince
of novgorod which is in russia so if
you're a slaw
devine was told you know resurrection
from his grave 1000 years later that he
is a symbol of Ukrainian independence
and that his order was given to an
American general but it's also claims
with the last 40 seconds here
what's going on here is also an asset
grab I mean churches are being sea
seized and and property being taken but
nectaries monasteries well I think it's
to make the split more permanent because
we had in the Ukraine the American soul
supported the Orange Revolution back in
2004 and again after they got stuck with
Yushchenko he was a realist was horrible
and they decided to go back to this idea
that they should harmonize relations
between the right buda western Russia
now
poroshenko just happens that the vast
majority crane is now believed more than
70 percent believe that the country is
going in the wrong direction so there is
the assumption that they could change
their mind again and realize the mistake
they keep trying to engineer this nation
that we still have a nationalism without
a nation we've run out of time here
gentlemen many thanks to my guests here
in Moscow this is the end of our
broadcast segment stay with us with the
extended version on our YouTube channel
see you next time and remember crosstalk
news
[Music]
now for the extended version of our
program we have political potpourri
Glenn you sent to me which I thought was
really quite um humorous because it's
about comedy from that very serious news
outlet BBC how Putin's Russia turned
humor into a weapon now I guess I'm the
oldest one here
Russians are supposed to be humorless in
dour
and dark but now they have weaponized
Cuba against the West here I mean what
does this tell us about perceptions of
Russia and rusev obeah well I think it's
this had to happen because the you know
propaganda usually works in moderation
once it goes completely out of control
it loses some of his credibility and I
think that over the last few years
everything doesn't matter what happens
around the world everyone it's always
Russia and so I think from the Russian
government's perspective they start to
push back a bit and mocking it when it
goes when it's really absurd so you know
for example if this yellow vest is
orchestrated from Moscow by you you have
to you of course have to push back but
it's hard to take it seriously when it
starts becoming this ridiculous so it's
become more and more common then that is
correct over the last years for Russia
to engage more in humor to dismiss all
these allegations but then the
accusation is Russia's now weaponized
humor they're essentially using humor to
to manipulate us all so it's quite that
fascinated by the levity you're treating
this extremely serious topic it is
obvious that Putin has weaponized
laughter the meme right he's like he's
the he's the king of the meat I happen
to know the truth that Peter sense of
sarcasm is considered assault with a
deadly weapon in Russia it could be it
could be a war crime yes d'etre the
truth BBC the West in general when were
not crying for you yes we are laughing
at you
exactly well I think that the United
Nations is going to ban humor in Russia
as a very dangerous weapon because I'm
going to tell you a Russian political
joke you know they were usually directed
against Brezhnev and now surprise
surprise guess whom they had directed
against the joke is that the British
police is asking you a scrip pal if she
saw anything suspicious before going to
England where she brought some buckwheat
for her father and we know the rest
right so she said I can't remember
anything like that but wait wait wait
wait I went to a supermarket to buy
buckwheat and for some reason there was
Putin in person selling it to me so this
is the Russian joke that needs to be
banned what are you doing now is a
Russian media loves that term highly
probable and what is it yeah okay set on
a wall but it's just throwing it's it's
throwing their own rhetoric right back
at them that's the whole point yeah but
also this argument that it's it fits
within a previous pattern because
because the argument is we don't really
need any evidence to accuse Russia more
because there's a pattern but the
pattern but the patterns every time we
accuse Russia listen to behind
everything
so now something new happens and we say
well obviously we have our long history
of Russia being behind everything no
evidence but but again they didn't make
a quantity of it becomes you don't need
evidence I think we should point out to
our viewers here cuz I think it's really
important the series of articles that
moon of Alabama has been running on this
integrity project I think with the
initiative it's fascinating okay it's
really the veil has been pulled yeah I
mean this is a a literal troll network
set up organized and funded by the
British Foreign Office to connect a
select group of journalists academic and
clusters these tankers in clusters in
countries around Europe who whose idea
is to do Rapid Response both online and
social media you know and in you know
their respective print and so on
whenever the British government directs
them to usually about something against
Russia because the one thing they all
have in common is they're all variant
Lee anti-russian but it goes even
further
because they have also started targeting
the leader of the Labour Party Jeremy
Corbyn posts where they accused him of
being a you so they're using government
money taxpayers money to smear the head
of the Labour Party they're also
operating in EU countries and meddling
in EU other EU countries politics that
way and they're actually in a circular
firing squad because one of the measures
in the leaked documents to measure how
successful they are is an increase in
government hardline policy towards
Russia
so they are a government-sponsored
non-governmental organisation right i
trolled Network that is basically
propagandizing their own government in a
circular firing squad and the
government's paying for it it's paying
for an organisation to propagandize and
disinfo themselves okay that's exactly
what's happening
EEMA well I think that the other
important event is that Kosovo is now
having an army and the West is surprised
whether it's a 5,000 man strong army
they want to establish the NATO in
Europe is against it the u.s. is for it
and the Serbs are obviously not very
happy about it because it's still
considered Kosovo a part of not only
that but the ships are also concerned
about the fact that the US has supported
this course of our army because they're
the SERPs know better than anyone what
lies the u.s. is capable of do you
remember the stories about 190,000
Kosovo Albanians killed in in Kosovo
before NATO intervened later on it
cracked up to be a complete complete lie
just a twosie falsity because if it had
been true you know there are just about
two million cause of Albanians every
family would have a member lost so I
just directed how the British press for
example kind
just forgot this story first they said
they were all buried at some parking lot
in Serbia then the dagger two things out
of this parking lot nothing was found
there so they just forgot the last
publication was in 2010
so the SERPs know full well how that
machine operates 120,000 cost of
Albanians dead weapons of mass
destruction in Saddam Hussein's palace
you know Maria boot in a honey trap for
Republican political consultants all
these lies they are the most dangerous
thing I think there is a real real
concern about what this army could do
therefore because there has been a real
ethnic cleansing and that is what has
happened to the Serbs in Kosovo under
the protection of the EU and NATO which
is the vast majority of Serbs have now
been ethnically cleansed out of Kosovo
the concern is that this could intensify
drastically because we still have in the
north a hundred and fifty thousand yes a
huge section of a Serb stair so it's if
they have an army that could really
intensify this ethnic cleansing but so
the EU had NATO's come out against it
but why is the US for it well first of
all the US has a rather large military
base camp a Bondsteel in kosovo and some
of there are a number of European Union
countries at least five of them that
still do not recognize Kosovo because
they have their own breakaway you know
potential sufferest groups and there and
they don't want to see a knock-on effect
and they they recognize that this was
you know a land grab a dismemberment of
a sovereign country you know for the
first time you know since the end of
world war two borders were changed by
force and a NATO Protectorate was carved
out but some of the NATO members are
smart enough to realize that this is
only going to potentially lead to a
powder keg not only in in Kosovo but
throughout the Balkans you know if there
are continual repressions and and
harassment of the you know the Serbs
you know the population is still living
in Kosovo and there are real fears that
this military will be used to further
that repression and and there's Glenn
said the ethnic cleansing is a real
possibility the Europeans are being a
little bit critical though because in
2008 against international law they did
unilaterally recognized independence of
Kosovo so they say independent country
but you're not allowed to build your own
army and indeed act as an independent
country and again this was warned yes
several years ago by the former Prime
Minister not until we get Serbia into
the EU well that's what goes because
that's not just Kosovo but it's also
Bosnia they both kind of little bit
between being a colony or independent
and that was the prime minister former
Prime Minister of Italy motto was it who
argued that it was a fear that both
Kosovo and Bosnia could become coldness
of the EU unless something was done now
the the past is an example because you
also have some intensification of
problems there's quite similar it's that
the EU is such a to cover stewardship of
implementing the Dayton Agreement in a
very very short in 95 we wish today was
that they should implement the anti
system where the Serbs got one entity
now the EU got all this power in order
to implement it however they realize
that only way they could be peace in
Bosnia to make it a member of the EU but
to be member of the EU you have to
centralize power so now they use their
powers to develop an empty system and
instead using these powers to kill off
the entity system so they can finally
join the EU however the Serbs they don't
want this in Bosnia so now they're using
the powers against it's the story of the
broken of the broken egg right you you
break it into pieces you can't put the
pieces back together again the egg was
the federal Yugoslav Republic it and and
they destroyed it we're running out of
time that is the end of our extended
version we hope you enjoyed it see you
next week and remember Rostock rules
[Music]